الى السودان
كشف اثري يحمل الكثير من الدلالات الفنيه
والتاريخيه اعلنت عنه بعثه دوليه متخصصه
في منطقه دونجلا العجوز شمال السدن الكشف
الذي رفده فريق مدعوم من مجلس البحوث
الاوروبي يعطي نتائج مهمه حول تحولات
الحضاريه لمجتمعات القرون الوسطى في تلك
المنطقه البعثه الدوليه تسعى لفك العديد
من الالغاز والجوانب الغامضه التي تحيط
بهذا الاكتشاف الذي يحتوي على لوحات ورسوم
غير معتاده للسيد المسيح والسيده مريم
العذراء والملك ميخائيل امبراطور مملكه
النوبه في ذلك الوقت يتمثل الكشف الجديد
في مجمع يضم غرفا مصنوعه من الطوب المجفف
بالشمس غطيت مساحتها الداخليه بمشاهد
تصويريه فريده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات